good morning john last year i made a
video about
how game of thrones can be seen as an
allegory for climate change and it
included
this line climate change is literally
the first global scale collective
problem our species has ever
faced and oh god so that made me think a
couple of things one was
is it really is it really like cancer is
a global scale collective problem
kind of so is nuclear proliferation
poverty and i guess it depends on what i
meant by collective and since i'm me i
guess i get to decide that maybe
i mean by collective that we all
contribute to it and we all can
and however small away have an impact
either positive or negative
on the problem through our actions and
through that lens maybe maybe global
warming is the first large-scale
collective
problem the world's ever faced but if
that is true then john
we've got a second and they could have
done without a second there was some
talk early on about how
covet would be a positive for the
environment
which i hated from the very beginning a
thing that is often overlooked or not
talked about enough is that like
overcoming climate change is going to
require prosperity
it requires a world in which there is
enough both for people to be
safe and happy and also for us to have
the resources necessary
to like free ourselves from the carbon
economy and that's a tall order because
a lot of our current happiness
and safety and health and prosperity
relies on the carbon economy i'm sorry
to say it that's the situation right now
we are incapable of guaranteeing
people's health and happiness
without spending extra resources on
combating climate change we're sitting
here with a global gdp for 2020 at
negative five percent that's
four trillion dollars and here's a wild
thing the un's upper estimate for how
much it would cost to fix climate change
four trillion dollars per year yes we
are incurring the costs of about one
half to one coveted epidemic
every year we do not tackle climate
change we have a very big global
collective problem right now and we're
spending a tremendous amount of
resources
either directly or through decreased
economic activity on that problem
as we should be and none of us know what
the end result is going to be but it's
not hard to imagine that there will be a
fairly significant period
of slow or even declining economic
growth and while that's happening we
won't be focused on climate change which
i understand but we also just won't have
the same level of resources we otherwise
would have had
to help free ourselves from the carbon
economy but also
i am seeing a clearer brighter light
being shined on the dangers of all out
individualism just as your freedom of
expression
doesn't always include the ability to
not wear a mask in certain places our
freedom to live however we want in this
world is going to be impinged upon by
the reality that living that way
is going to long term decrease our
ability to live in the world and so yes
there will be costs just as there are
costs to combating this epidemic they're
just much less bad than the cost of not
doing anything we've watched over the
last six months collective action
unlike anything i've ever seen in my
lifetime
maybe anything ever are there some
standout crap faces
yes do we know the ultimate impact
of their terrible behavior no we don't
and we may never but at least i have now
seen a large-scale collective action
of the kind if not the magnitude
necessary
to take on climate change and so if i am
more fearful because we're headed into a
less prosperous
world at least for now i am also more
hopeful because i have seen that people
can
and do make sacrifices when we see
what's really on the line
john i'll see you on tuesday